okay
okay good afternoon everyone and welcome
to this planning meeting my name is
lawrence walsh
and i am the chair just click that
and i am the chair of this planning
meeting my name is london chase planning
meeting um
councillor reagan williams is the vice
chair we have an attendance this
afternoon senior planning officers
together with officers from legal
highways democratic services and members
of council who make up this planning
committee
for everyone's information this meeting
is being live streamed and recorded for
subsequent broadcast
please can you mute your microphones to
minimize background noise
if you wish to speak to an item please
notify me
through the chat facility
so item number one is attendances
and um i have apologies from
councillors carey and council proctor
and we have councillor thomas and
councillor holden substituting this
afternoon
uh thank you gentlemen for joining us
and councillor dr barclay will be
joining us a little bit later
um she has other business but she will
be joining us just as soon as she can
um and for the members of the public i'd
just like to read out the members of
council
who are present um for the meeting we
have councillor morgan
councillor holden councillor minis
councilman thomas
councillor jerome councillor rigby
councillor stennit
councillor williams councillor hartley
council accordingly
councillor dr barclay and myself
councillor walsh
um ipso number two is declarations of
interest
members to give notice of any personal
or prejudicial interests
oh sorry sorry about that no problem
so as well as those uh names of councils
i've read out we have councillor win
stanley
um yes items uh declarations of interest
members to give notes of any personal
or prejudicial interest and the nature
of that interest relating to any item on
the agenda
in accordance with the adopted code of
conduct any members wish to declare
any interest to any of the items this
afternoon
no that's good um item number three is a
minutes to receive
and if so determined to approve the
correct record the minutes of the
meeting held on the 5th
on the 22nd of october 2020 with any
members
of the committee like to move those
minutes
happy to move chair thank you councillor
hartley
could have a second to please
um council accordingly you happy to
i'm looking for the chat facility is
anybody wishing to second those minutes
council half is happy to move them
i'm happy to second thank you council
accordingly
um answer number four is questions from
members of the public a maximum of 15
minutes will be allocated to
public questions submitted in writing to
democratic services
and the address the email address for
that is democratic dot services at
trafford.gov dot uk
by 4 pm two working days prior to this
meeting
questions must be within the remit of
the committee or be relevant
to items appearing on the agenda and
will be submitted in the order in which
they are received
and understand no questions have been
received for this afternoon
and item number five is the additional
information report
and i know members have been sent that
this afternoon
they've had sites of that and item
number six is applications to develop
and just before we
begin that a quick reminder to everyone
that as well as our local
knowledge we looked to the background
papers listed at the beginning of a
gender item six
as a basis for our decision making this
afternoon
so we're gonna go we're gonna we're not
gonna go
um to heat farm just yet i'm gonna take
it slightly out of order and we're gonna
go to
page 140 of your agenda papers
that's 187 to 189 marslin road in sale
[Music]
so page 140 of agenda and miss milner is
going to give us an introduction to this
item miss milner good afternoon
hear me and so i'm just going to share
my screen
you will see the um document
with the layout plan on yeah that's good
helen
great so this application just for
clarity
it is detailed in your report but that
just just be clear on the description
it is for the change of the partial
change of use of the first floor
of the um of number 187 and
the erection of a part three-story
two-story and single-story extension
following the demolition
of the existing two-story rear extension
there's external alterations
including a hip to gable roof
and the insertion of two side windows in
lieu
of a side burner which there have been
and it has six objections this is why
it's being referred to planning
committee
the objections raised and concerned
about parking impact on highways
the ability for change views to
a restaurant at a bar and these are
detailed within your
officer report and officers
um consider that the proposal in a in a
local
center oh sorry
and this is this is the existing plans
this is the existing elevation front
inside
this is the back the proposal to the
proposal
you still got the ground floor um
you'll extend out to the side and
they'll do a hip to gable up here
so you've extended up on this side and
to the back you can see this extension
so that is what it will look like uh
in terms of the proposed plans as you'll
see it's an extension
at first floor with an additional second
store and then these are photographs of
the existing
and then some wider views of the street
scenes
building here be extended
so in regards to the scale and massing
offices are satisfied that given the
design of the scheme and its location
and
it would have an acceptable impact on
the street scene and
in regards to adjacent residential
properties
there are a number of conditions um
which i would highlight which would use
and the ability of the
owner to insert new windows and to
further subdivide the
retail units or add an additional door
however
we'd also um further to the committee
report and the conditions outlined in
that we are proposing
an additional condition and which would
restrict
the commercial space at first and second
floor
to be ancillary for storage and office
space
for the ground floor commercial unit and
also in that condition say and it's not
to be made available for public use
now this is in light of the changes to
the use classes order
and that as a retail unit being under
e-class
the potential for that to then change
that space to become
other uses such as a bar or restaurant
we are not objecting to a change of use
at the ground floor should that happen
in the future that is part of these
classes order
to preserve the amenity of adjacent
neighbours
we are suggesting a condition
and i'll go back to that floor plan that
this storage in office space
showing at the first and second floor be
ancillary
and not i made available for public use
therefore subject to the conditions
outlined in the report and the
additional one i've just talked about
there we are recommending
approval thank you chair
[Music]
thank you miss milner um there's no um
no members of the public speaking this
item or council speaking to it and any
members of the committee wish to speak
councillor williams
thank you i i won't speak at great
length to
the um application before us um i i
think that you know this is a question
of balance and
having read the office of report i think
that i agree with the recommendation
that um officers have made i i
absolutely understand where residents
have come from and
why they might be a little bit concerned
about it um
future perhaps change of uses or or
about the impact of the extension but i
have to say i think that you know
when you read through paragraphs 13 to
25 of the report it strikes me that
officers have quite methodically
explained their own thinking about the
impact of the application
and they can demonstrate quite clearly
that
um the application before this is
reasonable and it's unlikely to have
any significant impact upon immunity for
neighbouring properties so as a
consequence chair i i'm happy to support
the application before us this evening
and i'm happy to move that we uh grant
the application in line with office of
recommendation
thank you chad thank you council
williams council accordingly
uh yeah i'm happy to second it but um
before i do the the the the question of
bin storage is mentioned and the
conditions attached to that
can i just check that that includes um
commercial
commercial bin storage um
that actually we would take that into
account there has to be
sufficient room for commercial bins um
councillor walsh and myself know
um how premises often use commercial
stall because we've got similar sites in
ghost hill
and um it's an issue where the
commercial bins go and
i don't want to see that um ignored
miss milner can you help us with that we
can we can
just add a word into the condition so
for the avoidance of doubt so if i add
in
household and commercial yeah that's
fine that would be brilliant yeah
yeah that's fine okay just just just
further to that miss milner
so there is space to accommodate a
larger bin
to the rear of that property there is
on on the plan on the floor plans it
does show an area of bin storage
so there could be bins that go in there
and
it's currently shared between 189 and
187
so it wouldn't necessarily have to be
the
the large europeans just because it's
commercial waste
right there has been storage space there
is
they wouldn't need to go onto the
alleyway at the back or
towards the gable end we within the
condition we would be looking to
for them to allocate space which they
have done on their plan
and that's what we'd be looking for them
to to record with obviously if people
put their bins down in the alleyway on
collection day we can't
you know intensive enforceability can't
be there all the time but we
do you think that that has the space as
demonstrated on the plans with the
accommodate yeah that's good um
with enough speaker councillor morgan
like to comment counselor morgan
[Music]
your mute counselor morgan
is that better that's better
to the chair yeah yeah absolutely i
think it must have been my headphones
um yeah just reiterating what counselor
williams said um
i looked at this and didn't see really
any reason to object to it on planning
grounds um
i looked at the representations that
members of the public made and again i
do understand the comments they've made
but i think most of them are
issues that are current at the moment um
people congregating in the corner
and any rubbish or parking issues i
think are issues that
um are at the moment and i don't think
this planning application will
significantly change those and
those are meant issues for other
committees um
i did read the points about restaurants
and i think it's fair
um the um conditions that we're putting
in place
and i do think it's probably worth
noting there are restaurants and bars at
the moment
so i don't really again think that this
even if it became a restaurant
bar i don't think would significantly
change those um issues so
again i i'll be supporting those at this
application tonight
thank you thank you councillor morgan
it's been moved by councillor williams i
don't think it's actually been seconded
would you sell for council accordingly
perhaps when it's a second date
happy to yeah thanks for that council
accordingly
removed by councillor williams and
seconded by council accordingly
that we grant this application i'll just
go through the
slow process of collecting everybody's
vote um councillor morgan
um live with officer recommendations
jeff
thank you council holden how would you
like to vote
councillor holden
we'll come back to you councillor
william i'm here i'm here oh you're here
you're here
yeah yeah the wrong microphone with the
word life okay
okay agreed in line with officer's
recommendations
thank you for that councilor minis how
would you like to
me vote support the uh office of
recommendation thank you
thank you councillor thomas how would
you like to vote
please support the council
recommendations check thank you
councillor jerome uh thanks i'll also
support officer recommendation to grant
thanks thank you
councillor rigby
thank you councillor stennett support
the application chair
thank you councillor williams
uh support officer recommendations thank
you thank you
councillor hartley thank you chair
export officer recommendation to grant
with condition thank you
council accordingly support the
officer's recommendation to grant thank
you i don't think dr barth is with us
yet um i'll be supporting the office
recommendation
council win stanley uh thank you chair
yeah
yes approving live offers recommendation
thank you councillor stanley that's
unanimous that application has been
granted thank you everybody
um we'll now go to
i can find it we'll now go to page 153
of your agenda that's three brooklyn's
rolled in sale
um and again we have an introduction
from miss milner
thank you chair so i'll just bring up
the
next presentation
[Music]
this application is for an outline
permission
for two semi-detached houses with all
matters reserved
and as you can see this is the site
location plan and the last site
edged in red and it would face out onto
brooklyn's crescent so it's to the rear
of three brooklyn's road
facing on two three facing on to
brooklyn's present
this is an indicative site layout to
show what two properties could
potentially
uh look like in terms of uh floor space
and this is indicative this is not to be
an approved plan this is just a
visualization of what could
go there and this is just the the site
images to show
um the site currently
with the existing guardian space of the
existing property and i would draw your
attention to the additional information
report
regarding the indicative site plan and
and just to
reassure members that the measurements
as outlined in the office report
are correct and to scale the indicative
plan that was
on the website was out of scale that has
now been revised but all the
measurements as reported
in the um committee report are correct
so this is reported to committee because
we have received in excess of six
objections the president's um concern
that there is an overdevelopment of the
site
and that it would cause issues with
parking and
an impact on residential amenity
and that would there would be noise
during construction and impact on
um wildlife and that um
just to be a general um impact on the
quality
of residents and surrounding the site
officers have have looked at the site
now it is outlined with all matters
reserved and we consider that
two dwellings can be accommodated within
the site
and the indicative site layout shows
that a two-story dwelling could fit here
and accord with our guidelines within
um pg one for residential development
however
we are not specifying um or not
approving the indicative layout because
we feel it is necessary to
have received all details from reserve
matters to them decide
on the exact uh layout and form that two
dwellings
should take on the site and we are
satisfied
and the subject to the details coming
forward through reserve matters that
this is an acceptable proposal and
therefore do recommend approval
thank you miss milner do we have mr
embrack
with us mr ambrack
yes yes mr ambreck you have three
minutes you're very welcome to speak
okay thank you um i'll leave at stanford
brooklyn's presence and
um i've sent the documentation through
already um
basically on brooklyn's presence um we
have a new build
number one a brooklyn's presence and
it's a three bedroom dome of bungalow
it's parked into two cars and where sort
of parking position does not dominate
the street scene
the total width for the plot is over 21
meters with the driveway
the remainder of the roadster has been
landscaped to a high standard and
accommodates
a front garden in a very shallow plot i
live at number seven the next door
neighbors at number five
and we live in the victorian semi
detached houses
the total width of the road frontage
both of our houses
is 16.8 meters so we're able to support
three or more cars off-road parking with
space and soft landscaping
the proposed development does not have
space for the parking required
if they're building two four-bedroom
semi-detached houses
need at least three parking spaces the
actual width
of the actual um of the um of the road
frontage is 12.7 meters
so my question is how is the proposal
going to accommodate parking
we're up to six cars three through each
running in such a restricted area
additional concern it's on a proposed
developments on a blind bend
and would inherently be unsafe we have
cars driving up and down brooklyn's
crescent the wrong way
most days um and the actual carriageway
is only 3.5 meters
wide we don't think it's safe in
addition to point 17 from observations
uh brooklyn's president does have a
specific character that will be
undeniably harmed by the creation of
overly densed
double driveways adjacent to each other
with little and no soft landscaping
a character would be detrimentally
affected
if we go to supplementary planning
guidance 9 entitled residential
development in brooklyn
it makes numerous references to the size
and massive developments relative to the
width of the plot
as this is a fundamental consideration
in the context current and quality of an
area
it is not notable that the relative
width of this development will be out of
key from the brooklyn's present
whilst the scale and massive other
properties may be intended to be similar
to other
properties the relative width of the
development
and the width of the plot especially
when you view from the street
be far greater and completely out of
proportion with the neighboring
properties
with respect to this there is absolutely
no basis i believe
for any objective assessment that would
conclude such an overcrowded
and already developed proposal with such
a narrow street scene
is is at odds with the character of
brooklyn's present
last section is a relating to point 28
the proposal is to replicate numbers
five and number seven's brooklyn's
present
which are four bedroom houses as you all
know um
for new bills if it's a two or three
bedroom property you need to have at
least two spaces
and if it's a new build it's a four
bedroom it's got to have at least
three spaces um there's not enough room
um there are literally in addition
around the area there's limited amounts
of non-restricted parking
within the vicinity of the proposed
development and it should be not but all
the properties on brooklyn's presence
have four or more bedrooms are able to
accommodate
three or more cars um also consequently
uh two double driveways um
doesn't ignores the need for pedestrian
pass it
it's got to be got to be safe to be able
to walk and down
in the crescent just let you know i'm
not anti-development
i just believe this is over development
um and will add nothing to the
uniqueness of a brooklyn's crescent
thank you mr embrace that's your three
minutes are up thank you for that
um it's councillor boys has he joined us
um
can officers tell me because councillor
boys with us yeah i'm with you
councillor wolf
ah councillor boys you have five minutes
councillor boys
all right thank you uh uh thank you mr
chairman for allowing me to speak on
this application
and what i've already submitted in
writing and i'm reading
is actually before the amended site plan
was published but you'll understand that
as i read it
i've lived within 400 yards of this
location for almost 30 years
and i'm very familiar with it especially
the narrowness
of the one-way highway which is
brooklyn's crescent
and the extreme narrowness of the
footpaths
uh having studied the plan namely
drawing four two two
three available on the council's website
i made a site visit to brooklyn's
crescent
indeed i have made a further visit only
this morning
the scaling of the plan suggested that
the frontage of the plot onto brooklyn's
crescent
approximated to a fraction more than 25
meters
i have measured this to the best of my
ability and in reality it actually
measures approximately 12.7 meters
the scaling of the plan also suggested
that the width of the carriageway
excluding footpaths onto which the plot
fronts
measures close to 7.5 meters and the
reality that it is close to 3.5 meters
i would add and i think as you will see
from the photographs
there is no footpath at all
at the front edge of this plot onto
brooklyn's crescent
because the boundary hedge is literally
alongside the kerbstones
these actual measurements led me to
realize that the plan is submitted
is wrongly scaled by a factor of
approximately two
which naturally has a monumental impact
upon the viability of placing
two dwellings on this site it would
appear that this era of scaling has come
about when copying the extract of the
ordnance survey map onto this drawing
and subsequently not correctly adjusting
the scale
given the dimensions and layout of the
highway
were two houses to be built it is highly
likely that vehicular access
to the frontage of the dwelling closest
to marslin road
might only be reasonably achieved by
driving past it
and refers onto it a totally
unsatisfactory situation
i therefore oppose this application in
its current form
and would ask that the council suggests
the need for a significantly revised
application thank you mr chairman
[Music]
thank you councillor boys any many
members wishing to speak to this item
councillor thomas
thank you chad i would just like to echo
knowing
brooklyn's present as my uh my partner
used to work in
one of the homes that was on brooklyn's
cleveland
the the parking issue is a huge issue
um the road is not wide enough in my
opinion
to accommodate uh excessive
vehicular parking there there is nowhere
for them to be as
uh from memory it says double yellow um
and as mentioned by the resin
uh the number of car parking spaces that
need to be available
on site for a four bedroom house i can't
see how that can be
fitted into the dimensions that we have
available
so i'm minded uh that i will be opposing
it
thank you thank you councillor thomas um
miss milner is going to come in and just
uh
clarify some information for us miss
milner
thank you i i need to be clear that this
is not an application for two
four-bedroom houses this is an occasion
for two houses and as detailed within
the officer report
in paragraph 28 we have said you know
the reserve matters stage will provide
additional details and that will dictate
the number of bedrooms that
this site can facilitate we haven't
specified um
a height we haven't said uh it's going
to be four bedroom houses and we feel
that
if two houses were to come in two small
houses there could be two bed houses
there could be three bed houses
you know that would then we would assess
that at that stage
in terms of our um policy with regards
to parking we've provided
design standards and we are not
approving we've not put forward an
application to approve two full bed
houses
so at this point we do we can't say
um what the parking requirements would
be
okay councillor minis you'd like to
comment
yes thank you chair um it's it's
interesting because if you look at it on
um if you looked at it as a planned
video ordinance survey
you think um you know why not there's a
access
uh through brooklyn's crescent when you
look at brooklyn's crescent
it's a tiny little road and the thought
of driving down there
and uh the amount of space you've got
which is occupied
by a hedge there a minute but you know
the amount of space to get
have potentially two driveways and how
on earth you would
get onto the driveway from that tiny
little road
um i don't care about the size of the
house
almost um my concern is not whether it's
a four bedroom or a three bedroom house
um or whatever house because we haven't
got there it's it it's only a
it's a it's it's a asking from
permission to build
two houses isn't it it's not it's about
what size they are
but whatever size they are and i think
in generally in planning terms we look
to have
parking for those houses we would look
certainly given how tiny that road is
and if it was even a little bit wider we
would look to have off street parking
and look at off street parking for those
two houses and
i don't think you can get it'd be very
very hard
two you're talking about two openings
in for separate openings almost or even
if slightly shared opening
to get into two drives of i don't think
this is really
um you know an adequate
idea of the idea is just wrong isn't it
you look at it
on paper looks okay look at it in real
life
not okay um and you'd look at it and go
that that's just not a feasible thing
and can you imagine
trying to even if you were to live at
one of those houses trying to get in
there
so for me it's a no-no and but i'm happy
to listen to what everyone else thinks
as well
thank you thank you councillor minis um
i think someone's asked what what we
what we've been asked to do today we're
asked we're asking him
he has to make a decision on an out an
outline application so
as miss milner's pointed out the the
sort of the distances
the the height of the houses uh whether
a car can drive into that or
drive out or or share drive or however
how that would work they would be the
reserve matters they would be the detail
what we've been asked today is the
principle can
are we acceptable do we agree that two
houses can go on that side that's i
think that's what we're being asked
today
um councillor morgan you'd like to
comment councillor morgan
thank you chair um i'm gonna probably
echo
my counselor thomas and councillor minis
um so i
actually misread this when i first read
the had a glance through the reports and
thought we were approving i was like
well of course you can fit
one house on there and then i was very
surprised when it
too and looked at the details of the
plan so
the area which is we're looking at
could fit two houses comfortably but
it's the shape
the shape of that plot is an odd shape
yeah because it's it's not a rectangle
we're proving a very odd shape
um and i
just agree with what everyone said about
the difficulty i cannot see
you you'd be able to do this so i
actually i thought no i'm going to have
a visit to the site because i want to
look at this properly
it is a really tight road really
really tight road and there's lots of
them in you know round trafford
we all i'm sure everyone on this
committee will have
roads in their ward which have similar
issues and
i just cannot see i don't doesn't matter
what size of property
i cannot see this working um on this
road
with the issues that you will have this
will um i mean there are issues in terms
of the development which
people have represented i don't think
this is necessarily a reason to oppose
it but i think it will cause real issues
during the development for people
and residents there but i just think
when these are built
i think this is going to be this is an
over development of a site this size
if this was approval for one house um
i wouldn't see i wouldn't even possibly
even commenting because i think it would
be obvious
to me that it could could be quite big
one but a big
one house but i cannot see us being able
to do this for two houses so
um i i'm highly unlikely that i was
supporting this because i do genuinely
think it is an over development of
this particular site it's not because of
the area of it
but the shape of this site means i
cannot see
how we could you could get this to work
and not adversely affect residents in a
way that i think is
unfair to them thank you jeff thank you
councillor morgan
uh miss milner did you want to come back
in
um not specifically sure but i would i
would reiterate um
in response to councillor um boyce's
comments this is
um the indicative plan is not for
approval
so we are specifically saying we are not
approving four-bedroom houses because we
do not feel at this stage
we can dictate the number of bedrooms
that could be accommodated
equally and in terms of council and
minister's comments about two separate
driveways
the design of the driveway the design of
the access has yet to
to come forward we're not looking at any
details and we can't make assumptions
about
how the design and layout would would
would play out on the site
we're saying we're purely looking at
could this site in principle accommodate
two dwellings
and the design the layout the size
is yet to be determined it's purely on a
matter of principle
thank you for that council owens
councillor and stanley you'd like to
comment
yeah thank you chair it's the um
it's the approvement the approval in
principle which are being requested
which concerns me
because and then they'll like go along
what
the members of the committee have said
the
the access to this site looks very very
difficult
and the and i know they're not part of
this
application they're just indicative the
fact that there's two houses on there
i i could never see how that could the
access could ever work
this is an extremely narrow road um
and even when i went to do my cypress i
ended up caught behind another car going
round the road because i could i
couldn't get past it and if there's
another two hours on there i told you
how it could work so
i guess what i'm saying is that without
the actual detail plans what's going to
go on the site it's very difficult to
to make a proper decision and i've seen
too many examples where you you get kind
of salami slash developments where
there's an agreement in principle and
then there's a an agreement to do
something extra and something actually
something extra and you end up with
something you didn't want in the first
place
so at this stage i think what i'm saying
is i'm minded to re
refuse uh to vote against granting the
principal development with the provider
of that if the developer brought forward
a detailed proposal for the site i think
the committee and then brought back to
the committee i feel
i'd be very happy to look at that then
on the specifics
so at the moment i'm minded to to vote
against
um granting a improvement in principle
all right thank you chair
thank you councilwoman stanley um
councillor hartley
uh thank you chair i i um i visited the
site as well and i would
i'd agree with the comments made by
other members that that the site does
look tight
uh it does it's not a particularly wide
frontage
um but i think you know at the moment
i'm going to
uh vote with the officer's
recommendation because i can't see a
planning reason
to refuse this i think it's the
applicant's right to
only apply for outline permission for
the principle of development if that's
what they if that's what they wish to do
um i haven't been out with with uh with
my tape measurers councilor boys
obviously has
but um you know officers have assessed
the site and they
are satisfied that in principle two
dwellings can be accommodated on that
site
so the applicant isn't isn't applying
for a particular size of house or
particular configuration
um you know the site does look tight for
access
but there could be one drive could be a
shared drive we don't know any of that
yet
um and you know if it can't be made to
work you know
if the applicant can't come up with
plans for
you know dwellings that are feasible you
know if they want to have
two four bed semis there with separate
drives it's not if that's not feasible
then it
it either won't come before the
committee or you know if it did we'd
have a good reason
to to refuse at that point so i think
bearing in mind we're only being asked
to approve the you know an outline
application for the principle
of developing two houses on that site
officers are satisfied that in principle
it can accommodate those
those two dwellings i can't see a
planning reason to refuse um
the road is never on the road is tight i
used to live quite quite near there
but that that's a factor already isn't
it there are already residences on that
street
and you know the access down that road
is already not good but that's that's
not the applicant's responsibility
frankly you know
there are double yellow lines along the
road people shouldn't be parking there
if they are it's a highways matter
that's that's not the applicant's
responsibility you know residential
developments
are there already um so that that's
where i'm at the moment uh
it does look tight it doesn't doesn't
look as if it would be possible but i
don't think i'm
in a position to to to go against the
officer's recommendation that it that it
would be possible in principle to
to fit to two dwellings on that site um
with you know
all the other matters um still reserved
um so at the moment chair would uh would
vote to accept the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you um councillor williams you'd
like to ask a question
thank you sure um i i did indicate that
i wanted to ask a question i
think that i may already know the answer
given what what's now
um been said by um officers previously
but i just noted that
um a lot of what other members have to
say
have had to say in the debate seems to
relate to me to
issues that relate to highway at
highways um
and upon reading the report it does say
that no objection subject to future
details being agreed
was the consultation response from the
local highways authority
made the point of looking on the
planning portal and i i couldn't see
any consultation response from the lha
so i just wanted to raise that i don't
know if there's a response and
in in respect of what my current
thinking is
i i find myself i think uh similarly
minded to counselor hartley
and i'm not sure that i'm particularly
enthusiastic about
principle of development here um for two
two houses however i think that
you know it's an outline application and
in the event that a future application
comes forward
um the specific properties to be built
residents will have an opportunity to
object to that point and we would find
ourselves
as a committee again looking at that
individual application so i think in
that respect
i'm similarly minded to council hartley
in um
voting in favor of office of
recommendation
and i just wanted to put them back up my
own thinking thank you
thanks for that um mr everson do you
want to make a comment
evening chair um yes i would reiterate
council hartley's point
in what we've actually done as part of
our consultation
um at this stage we are agreeing the
principle of a development
in that location but as yet we don't
know how
large those two dwellings will be um
yes the road is narrow but equally there
are a number of dwellings already off
that road
and there's houses close by which have
drives
which do go out onto that road but so
really reiterate council hartley's
position in terms of
how the local highway authority have
assessed the application
okay um councillor holden you want to
ask your question
now my question was what are we being
asked to agree and i now understand that
right okay you're happy with that um
counselor boys has
made a comment in the chat i can't
really bring you back in
counselor boys you've had your your five
minutes won't be right for us to bring
you back in
um do we have any other speakers i'll
just
uh councillor jerome would like to
comment
thanks sure i won't speak for too long
but um
i just wanted to agree with councillor
hartley and councillor williams really
um i think there are concerns but
obviously that and that the residents
have mentioned and councillors but
um if you if you do look at the plot the
plot does look
big enough for two houses for me um but
as you can see the lara
the plot does narrow as it comes towards
the the road
but i think those issues are really to
be navigated in a future planning
application
um whether the you know parking can be
accommodated and how it would be
accommodated but i think
with this application we're here to uh
look at look at the principle of it so i
can't really see
any planning matters that would justify
refusing it
so i think i'll i'll be joining
councillor hartley and williams in
in um agreeing with officer
recommendation here
thank you chair okay um
so i think we've had a win a proposal to
refuse the application i think we did
anybody propose that we refuse the
application
that we refuse the application and
counselor morgan did you second it
have it second it okay so we'll take the
review
have we got a proposal to grant the
application
yeah chair yes i'm about to um propose
that we uh
grant yeah thank you anybody willing to
second
councillors have this proposal that we
grant this application well trevor's
second that proposal i'm
happy to do that thank you so we'll take
the refusal first
um
we need a reason for refusal so what
would be the reason for refusal
a councillors minister morgan
um my grounds would be um actually
highways based because um
and the re i know that we haven't
obviously determined how the driveway
would be
if it's a shared driveway etc but um
to me having this indicative uh
you know proposal to to the principle of
building two houses
uh goes down that road we then are
committed down the road of building two
houses
whatever form they take and to me it
causes a highways issues is a tiny road
um and to me it is a highways problem
highways and parking
is my reasons thank you okay
does that satisfy our officers um miss
coley
no a highways problem isn't really
enough what what
highway's problem highway's problem in
terms of
cars getting in and out to
that you know to into a
i thought i presume a driveway of some
sort
to get into there to get in and out um
when you've got things so when you've
got um
it's on the bend and you've where you've
got the building so nearby
i think i don't think it's big enough i
think there's a safety issue there
to me um i understand that that you're
saying that the highways
department said it's okay because we
haven't determined exactly how it's
going to be
but i disagree that no no
no i understand that i just i haven't
heard what the from members what the
consequence
of that would be there needs to be a
consequence
that is that that is harmful that that's
what i haven't heard yet
you know my view would be it's an over
development of that site
and the highways issue is an element of
the over development of that site
yeah but
but you still haven't said what the harm
is
i i i see what members are saying but
yeah but you you've taken it to
one point you need to move it to the
next point which is what the heart
what where is the harm well the end the
end harm is safety isn't it to nearby
residents
that already and i think you land up
you know people get run over it's a
safety issue
that's what you land up with tiny little
roads like that having
basically over developments that's what
is the end result isn't it
it's a safety issue okay that's fine
that's fine we just we
you just need us to get we just need to
get okay that's fine that's fine
highways and safety thank you
yeah are we happy i think what we're
saying um
miss coley what uh councilman mason
counselor morgan
in principle they can't see that any
form of two houses
can go on that side they can't they
can't foresee any
um possibility how it possibly could
could work on that
so they can't accept the principle that
it can go on the site
i understand that but they need to
identify some harm arising from that
in order to refuse the planning
application you can't just say
i can't see how it can get on
okay we'll go to the vote and we'll take
the refusal first
i'll go through everybody councillor
morgan how would you like to vote
god i'd like to vote in favor of the
refusal
is that the correct wording yeah against
the officer's recommendation
officer recommendations yeah okay
councillor holden how would you like to
vote
i would like to vote for the councillors
for the officer's recommendation thank
you
councillor minis how would you like to
vote
against officer recommendation thank you
thank you
councillor thomas how would you like to
vote i'd like to vote against the
officer's recommendation please check
thank you councillor jerome how would
you like to vote
i'll be supporting officer's
recommendation thank you
councillor rigby are we supporting
officer's recommendation
thank you councillor stennett how would
you like to vote
in the office's recommendation thank you
councillor williams
[Music]
[Applause]
it's against the refusal chair thank you
against the refusal but you
you're sorry you will take you're right
classy when she's right taking the
refusal first
so against the refusal
um councillor hartley how would you like
to vote
thank you yeah against the against a
motion to refuse yet
it's refusal council accordingly how
would you like to vote
against the motion to refuse chair thank
you
councillor dr barclay how would you like
to vote
she's not here yet i'll be voting in
favor
of the refusal
and councillor when stanley how would
you like to vote
thank you chair in favor of the refusal
in favor of the refusal
um someone like to help me with the
counting perhaps one of the officers
i'll do it myself but i'll need someone
to
verify
i guess i get um five in favor of the
refusal seven against chairman yeah
seven again so it's um the application
has not been refused
will go to to the officer's
recommendation up but
but that that refusal proposal to refuse
has been lost
okay we'll go to the vote on the
officer's recommendation
um councillor morgan how would you like
to vote
against officer recommendations to
approve check
councillor holden how would you like to
vote in support
of the officer's recommendation thank
you
council and minis how would you like to
vote
officer recommendation thank you thank
you councillor thomas how would you like
to vote
against the officer recommendations
thank you chair thank you councillor
jerome how would you like to vote
voting in favor of the recommendation
chair thank you
councillor rigby how would you like to
vote
thank you councillor how would you like
to vote what a recommendation
of the office's report thank you
councillor williams how would you like
to vote uh
in favor of officer recommendation chair
thank you thank you
councillor hartley how would you like to
vote thank you chair in favor of the
officer recommendation thank you
thank you council accordingly how would
you like favor of the officer's
recommendation
thank you council dr bark is not with us
i'll be voting against the officer's
recommendation
council win stanley oh thank you chair
against the officer recommendation
you're voting against joshua's
recommendation as well thank you for
that councilman stanley and i think
that's
pretty certain that um there's more
people in favors the majority of people
in favor of the officer's recommendation
so that uppercase has been granted in
principle
um for two bedroom two possibly two
houses on that on that side the
application's been granted
thank you everybody um
council dr barclay isn't with us yet if
we begin the item and she arrives
she won't be able to take part am i
correct in saying that
i'm looking for guidance from our
officers you're right in saying that
councilor walsh yes i think she needs to
hear
um i'm afraid she turns up now she won't
be able to take part she's very welcome
to
to listen but she won't be able to take
part in the proceedings okay
so we'll go to page one at um
of your agenda that's land of heath farm
lane in partington
and we have an introduction from mr
pearson
yes thank you chairman um so i've just
shared my screen with you there i hope
you can see that
um that's the site plan um
i'll just run through these slides first
so you can see it so i mean this
application relates to the the former
uh parchington gas works on broadway and
heath farm lane
impartington and then a couple of uh a
piece of adjacent land here as well
off broadway the application been for
up to 600 dwellings seeking full
planning permission
for 148 dwellings and outlying
permission for up to 100
for up to 452 dwellings
the application was uh previously
considered by committee on the 11th of
april
last year when the committee resolved to
grant permission subject to a legal
agreement
in accordance with officer
recommendation
so just i'll just give you a quick
reminder of um of the scheme
as couple of shots of the um of the site
there
you can see the aerial view uh over here
um and then some photographs down below
from street level
um and then just skip over that
and there's the site layout so there's
manchester road down here broadway down
here
so that's the parcel of what was fairly
uh kind of scrubby land previously so
an element of housing on there and then
this is the gas works site this larger
area here
and there are two areas of the site you
can see that have got
houses drawn on them those represent the
the layout for the full
elements of the scheme very significant
area of open space here and then beyond
that
we've got more housing another
significant area of open space
and then more housing beyond
so that was the layout um
that was the detail phase you can see
the detail of the
uh of the of the layout there um
officers and committee obviously at the
time uh
last year thought that was an acceptable
form of development
um i'll just skip onto once there's a
parameter plan in relation to the uh
the outline elements some of the access
roads
and then some images of the houses
from phase one some of the house types
we thought they were easily attractive
there's a visual and then i think we
just got one more
there's some of the houses from from
phase two they're trying to create a
more
traditional feel with those designs um
close-up and then there's a
visual from um from phase two
so um as i say back in april last year
uh we all thought that was fine and the
resolution was to grant subject to a
legal agreement
um now that legal agreement has not been
completed there have been discussions
relating to
in the main relating to um
how we how we re-look at viability and
future phasing
but whilst we've been doing that there
has been
um a material change in planning
circumstances
in that as a result of the changes to
the sill regulations in september
last year the council can now take both
section 106 contributions and
seal monies towards the same piece of
infrastructure
so those of you that were on committee
um
you will remember from us sorry only
from last month that we
approved a strategy to meet the funding
gap for the carrington relief road
so consequently and in line with the
formula used in that report
this application now proposes a
contribution of just over 1.6 million
pounds
towards the carrington relief road and
consequential amendments to the section
106 agreement
and relevant conditions
uh the applications accompanied by an
environmental
statement let's assess the likely
significant
environmental effects of the development
we had 11
letters of objection and one letter of
support
but the main issues raised being poor
transport infrastructure
additional traffic inadequate public
transport
lack of local facilities impact on moss
land wildlife and bird species
contamination and health risks air
pollution and increased flooding
the sites within the carrington
strategic location
and air identified in the core strategy
for
1560 new dwellings employment
development and supporting
infrastructure
so we'd said the principle of
residential development in this location
is acceptable
will contribute significantly towards
addressing the identified housing land
supply shortfall in the borough and of
course would contribute towards the
regeneration of partington
as i mentioned before in terms of layout
and design the proposal was considered
to be acceptable
in this location and should deliver a
high quality scheme
with significant areas of open space
with london tree planting and children's
play areas
the contribution to the carrington
relief road will
obviously assist in bringing forward the
road infrastructure
necessary to make the wider strategic
location
and beyond a sustainable
location for development not just this
development but for
for other development the relief road
will also mitigate the full transport
impacts of this development
the proposal hasn't changed in that no
improvements to public transport are
proposed as part of this
application there are also insufficient
primary school
places in partington to accommodate the
demand generated by the full development
again no change from the position in
april 2019
so these are identified as as adverse
impacts to be weighed in the planning
balance
due to the still regulations context the
council was unable to seek
contributions to those matters at the
time of the previous resolution
given this position and considered in
the round it was considered
inappropriate and unnecessary to seek
contributions this time
too proposal would result in a loss of
existing woodland
trees and hedges and disturbance to
habitats and species
which these support however the
proposals will result
in an overall net gain in biodiversity
with retention and management of
woodland and provision of substantial
new areas of open space
woodland trees and hedgerows wildflower
meadow and wetland
the skiing will provide 100 affordable
dwellings to be provided by trafford
housing trust
with the benefit of a homes england
grant and which will include shared
ownership
and rent to buy units in the strategic
locations
policy requires a level of affordable
housing determined by a site-specific
viability assessment
which could be up to 40
if future phases of development on this
site will be subject to a viability
review to assess whether
further affordable units can be
delivered in future phases
the planning balance section of the
officer report makes it clear that in
relation to paragraph 11 of the mppf
there is no clear reason for refusing
the development posed
and the benefits of the scheme are
considered to significantly and
demonstrably
outweigh the adverse impacts
the application of paragraph 11d is an
important material consideration
which should be given significant weight
and justifies the departures from the
development plan policy
identified in the officer report
no other material considerations have
been identified which would warrant a
different view being taken
the application is therefore recommended
for approval
subject to a section 106 legal agreement
and a list of conditions
if i can also just draw the committee's
attention to the additional information
reports
within that we've had one further
representation
uh relating to concern about
mud being spread all over broadway that
unfortunately is a result of the
developer having already started on site
notwithstanding the fact that planning
permission has not yet been granted
um also there's been um
a change to the the trigger for the
payment of the carrington relief road
i'm not sure where i have certificate
the developer has agreed to make this
1.6 million pound payment for the
road um and it's considered now in the
additional information reports
that that contribution should be paid on
confirmation by the council
that the carrington relief road will be
delivered so that would come at a point
at which
if and at which planning permission is
granted for scheme for the carrington
relief road
the additional information report also
sets out
what might happen should the carrington
relief road not come forward
in that event then we would the council
would seek to uh introduce another form
of mitigation
uh together with the developer and that
would probably
be a further flitstone road junction
improvement scheme which
the the applicant had originally
identified
so some of the monies that the developer
has
agreed can be put towards the the
carrington relief road the 1.6 million
some of that
money would then go towards the further
flexton road junction
i think it's unlikely that the cost of
those works would be the same as the
as the relief road and then finally the
the last points uh substantive point in
the
additional information report is a
revision to the trigger for
viability reviews um
and we had previously uh suggested that
they should
should be triggered by different phases
of development coming forward
we're now recommending that those um
reviews
happen according to the the number of
units delivered on the site and that's
set out
in the additional information reports
um i don't want you to think
i mentioned the full back position of
the flexton road junction improvement
scheme there
um obviously the council's intention uh
is to deliver the relief road so
we would suggest that it's unlikely at
this point that that would happen
because of the intention to deliver the
relief road
okay so that that concludes that
introduction
and chairman back to you
thank you mr pearson um do we have mr
scott with us this evening mr scott
yes good afternoon mr scott you have
three minutes mr scott thank you thank
you it's a pleasure to be sat in front
of planning committee tonight
i've not visited for a while and i do
look forward to actually when i can
visit back in person um
sorry members will no doubt remember
that i attended planning committee in
april 2019 where this scheme was
previously approved
the scheme in front of planning
committee is in essence the same scheme
that was previously approved
but is being brought back with further
changes in the section 106 agreement
because
mr pearson just outlined the partnership
is pleased that the scheme still has the
support of planning officers
we remain proud of the scheme and that
it will deliver residential development
on a contaminated site in part in turn
an area that needs new housing
development to support its wider growth
and to meet the council's ambitions in
this area the first phase of the
development
which will deliver 148 new homes of
which 50
affordable a mix of shared ownership and
rent to buy
will be owned and managed by trafford
housing trust these homes will provide a
unique opportunity to allow residents
to get on the housing ladder and support
economic growth of
the partington area in addition the open
market
sale homes will also provide affordable
home ownership option
compared to some other areas of the
borough where first-time buyers
are priced out of the market and
families are priced out of the housing
market
as uh mr pearson has said the later
phases of the development also in terms
of affordable housing
which will be secured through the
enhanced profit capture
mechanism which will ensure that any
additional profits will go to affordable
housing on this side which we are keen
to deliver as traffic housing trust
the mechanism enables us now to bring
forward the development of contaminated
brownfield site
which delivers affordable housing in
excess of other schemes in the area
whilst also maximizing the level of
housing delivery
in the future the main reason this
scheme is back in front of planning
committee tonight
is the council's proposal to secure
additional developer funding
to support the development of the
current relief road the heath ju
he found jv and myself after working
traffic for 18 years
are fully aware the benefit the current
relief road will bring to trafford
parkington and our
individual development and whilst our
original scheme was approved by members
we understand that more technical work
has been undertaken by the council on
the
relief road and the council is seeking
additional contributions in this area
on this basis we are pleased that we
have managed to come to a positive
agreement with the council
which will see the partnership
contribute an additional 1.6 million
towards this road
the partnership board pleased that we
are able to contribute to this much
needed improvement
to traffic's transport network and are
fully supportive of developing places
and neighborhoods
not just housing which we believe the
relief road will contribute towards
we therefore hope to gain the support of
planning committee tonight
so that this partnerships and traffic
housing trust the jv for heat farm
can come continue to deliver much needed
housing traffic
and we can continue our relationship and
positive relationship we have with
trafford council
thank you chair
thank you mr scott um council dr
barclay's joined us
um before i bring anybody in i know she
wants to take part in this debate can we
have some uh
clarity from our legal
uh person may i just mention that i
joined shortly after um our officer
started the introduction to the
application so i've heard
the um person speaking for the
application
thank you okay sorry i would say um
i would say no because the application
had um because david had started
speaking
yeah we did uh council dr barclay we did
we did uh wait a couple of moments when
the the previous application finished
and i did ask
uh miss colburn if um if he could take
part
if he came after david started to speak
and
she did advise me that that you wouldn't
be able to take part
you need you need to be here absolutely
at the beginning of his
of his speech so um i'm afraid you won't
be i'm afraid you won't be able to vote
thank you thank you council dr barclay
um some members wish to speak councillor
williams like to comment
thank you chad i won't speak at great
lengths to the application i think
because
really the application is only back
before committee
owing to a technicality around
um the mechanism for generating and
receiving contributions from developers
i mean as
as page two of the um committee report
states it says the report remains
substantially the same as that
uh considered at the 11th of april 2019
committee
now at that committee meeting i i did
make um a number of remarks and i think
for me
uh the most important one is that as a
local authority
we prioritize and we want to prioritize
brownfield a brownfield first approach
to development
as far as i'm concerned every unit that
we managed to deliver on this site is
one less unit that will be delivered
on a green belt site elsewhere in the
bubba
so i'm enthusiastic about this
development chair i'm pleased that we've
managed to
um extract further contributions from
the developer
in respect to highways improvements
i i'm not uncritical about aspects of
some of the application i know that um
we received a representation from the
developer that talked at length
about the affordable housing aspect but
quite frankly i remain unhappy about the
tiny breakdown of the affordable
housing provision that's outlined in
paragraph 39 of the report
um i don't i'm not enthusiastic about
when to buy
and i'd like to have seen an affordable
or social rented
option provided and
in addition to that as mr pearson
highlighted in his
uh introduction the affordable housing
that has been delivered has
been done so by a government grant
rather than from any contribution from
the developer
themselves and i think really as a
registered provider of social housing
the developer needs to reflect on the
fact that they haven't been prepared to
put even one unit
of social housing in themselves now
that said that argument's been had at
the last committee
uh report at the last committee meeting
where the application was approved
and my opening comments about my
enthusiasm for the development of a
brownfield
site remains so i'm happy to support
this application
this evening share and i i hope that
other members feel
uh similarly thank you chad thank you
councillor williams councillor hartley
did you want to ask a question
yes please chair i could um i i
wasn't on the committee when when this
item um
came before you uh last time um i
appreciate the knowledge what councilor
williams has said that
it seems to be back on on a technicality
but
i suppose before i before i sort of say
what i think about the application
one of the things that i wanted to raise
i think is more of a question really
which is about
the the traffic impact
um so this is sort of around
paragraph 140 of the report which is
page
uh page 60 of the of the pack
um so this this sort of section just
just before and just after there as well
is all about the
the impact of the um of this development
um and and it and there's a relationship
with what's been approved at carrington
village
so obviously i i i
i heard and would support what mr
pearson said that hopefully the
carrington relief word will will will be
delivered
there's a lot of there's a lot of
commentary in the report about um
if if the if the current relief rule
isn't delivered about the mechanism that
will be used
to secure to get some funding for
mitigation of the uh of the junction at
flixton road
um but the the report also um
talks about uh another junction so
paragraph 140 at the end of that at the
end of that paragraph it does
say that the the carrington spur
carrington lane junction
um will continue to operate over
capacity and
that mitigation will be will be required
um
and i've tried to sort of get some
further information and so what concerns
me i suppose is that
is there isn't really any mention in the
report about how that mitigation at
at that junction current and spur
current layer junction how that
mitigation
would occur if the carrington relief
road wasn't
delivered whereas there is a lot of
commentary about
how the mitigation will be delivered at
flixton road if the relief road isn't
built and there's a condition built in
just to sort of say you know it'll be
one or the other
so i just wonder if if one of the
officers mr everson could could sort of
help me with that because i would have a
concern if
if there isn't a mechanism to ensure
that mitigation is put in place
if if the relief real doesn't it isn't
built that would strike me as an adverse
impact but it's not
it's not really discussed in the report
thank you
mr everson would like to comment
yeah um sorry um yeah in terms of um
the the junction in question when the
the application first came before
members
the when we analyzed the the impact of
the development
we didn't see that the impact of this
heath farm lane was significant whereby
we could justify any improvements
at that that particular junction and so
that was the reason
why this joint this loop to mitigate the
impact
at that particular point the main
concern we had with this application was
flexton road issue woodrow junction um
and the contribution is is hopefully the
the right way go forward but
alternatively there was some proposals
for
the flixton road issue woodrow junction
are you satisfied with that council
hartley
no not entirely chair no i have i have
to say because i don't
that's that's sort of not what the
report says i suppose so that that
my so paragraph 140 that i talked about
that
does say that the the traffic assessment
and the technical note
confirmed that that these junctions
above the junctions
will continue to operate over capacity
with increases in queuing and delay and
that mitigation will be required
um so if it's
so it's partly linked to the carrington
village development isn't it my
understanding is if
if they go above 99 houses they will
have to make a contribution
to mitigate both of those junctions
but if if they don't get to that point
uh and all of this development goes
ahead 600 houses up 600 houses
then my understanding is that the report
is saying that we'll have an impact on
both of the junctions
now that impact will be relieved if the
carrington relief road is built but if
not i don't i don't
see any mitigation there so um
so it would be useful to get some
clarity like if that's the case that is
an adverse impact and i think a fairly
significant one okay
sorry could i just come back on that
please yeah yeah
okay in terms of um improvements along
that corridor
the carrington village application
does actually improve the
the carrington lane spur junction
so that that actual improvement is is in
hand
um and we've the council have received
the contributions from the carrington
road
carrington village application and those
improvements at that junction are
are due to go in and then over the next
few months
so that is that those works have been
triggered
equally there's some improvements at the
flixton road issue woodrow junction
again which will be coming along online
over the next few months at the same
time as the
the works at the spur carrington spur so
there are improvements which are are
actually now coming forward
which probably weren't the case at the
time of this application
um but we were aware of that so there
are improvements
at both those junctions over the next
few months
the the consideration was with regards
to the heath farm lane application
and the farmland application
doesn't have a significant impact at
carrington lane
in in the on the basis that works are
already taking place
so we were satisfied with the impact of
heath farm lane
with the exception of issue wood road
flixton road junction
so this particular variation
gives an opportunity hopefully for the
bypass to come forward
which is the council's preferred option
but if if something happens that that
doesn't come forward
then there is an opportunity to further
improve
lexton road issue woodrow junction
council halfway
well chair yeah i think i think that i
just that that satisfies me i think i
think if those improvements
are going to be made at that at that
junction karen's main count and spur
then i can understand why it's not
provided for i was just puzzled as to
why
um you know the two junctions had had
been treated differently so if that if
those works are going to go ahead
then and the mitigation is being put in
place then then i'm happy with that yeah
yeah
okay thank you councillor rigby you'd
like to comment
yes thanks very much indeed john good
evening um
yes without doubt the redevelopment of
this large site is
has the potential to make a real
contribution towards the regeneration of
passington
which we all know has been well
needed for some time and welcome excuse
me
my voice cracks up um
certainly being a specialist part of the
existing site is not the majority has
been
really contaminated brownfield site and
is calling out for redevelopment
reading the report and as we all know
there are many and many issues to
consider
including the necessity for a carrington
relief road
which must be pursued if the key is
success is to be achieved
but there's another issue chairman which
is close to my heart
which is equally important if not even
more so
if this development as rather other
developments in partington
are to be overall success in the years
to come
on polygraph 109 page 51 members will
see
the report clearly states that the nppf
states it is important that the
sufficient choice of school places
is available to meet the needs of
existing and new communities
local planning authorities should take
proactive and positive
and collaborative approach to meeting
this requirement
and to the development that will widen
the choice in education
and work with schools promoters and
delivery partners
and statutory bodies to identify and
resolve key planning issues before
applications submitted
chairman i may be totally wrong but i
can't find any evidence of this
in fact i'm really concerned the lack of
school places
this is clearly a very real concern
in paragraph 115 on page 52 it states
as the expansion of existing primary
schools and provisions of the new
primary school in carrington
are on the cil register 123 list no
mitigation
is proposed in this application to
address the adverse effect
that will be insufficient places
imparting to
for primary school-aged children the
consequences of this
are that some pupils will need to travel
further
in order to find a place further the
accepted
two miles you know is this really
acceptable
in the following polygraph it states
that the applicant has identified
that there are some capacity outside the
borough in primary schools in salford
and in warrington really what a family
supposed to do
to go to school in salford scrubbing the
manchester ship canal
you know this is i can't see any sense
how on earth can families be expected to
move into new homes
in excitement in partington if there are
no school places for the children
people moving to trafford all of
trafford year on year
in order to gain a place as a traffic
school
if the regeneration of parties and
encouraging this to be successful
it is vital that there are successful
schools right within
their own communities show me a
successful community chairman and i'll
show you a successful school
and vice versa i spent 30 years until
retiring two years ago working
in a number of schools including 17
years in partington
working i'd like to think successfully
to raise standards
i know it's vital for families to have a
real opportunity
to send their children to a local school
of the three primary schools in
partington and the one secondary
how many of these schools have actually
been consulted to look at future
capacity
one school is a voluntary aided and
therefore
the diocese are key and the other three
are academies of
ultra government trust board
i accept that trafford admissions team
have been contacted and i admire the
traffic admission teams
greatly but they can only identify
numbers the infrastructure of the
schools
and can the infrastructures of the
schools
meet demands is surely a case for the
schools themselves
but nobody's contacted them to my
knowledge
this report makes gloomly reading as
regards school places
being made available and as a result i
really believe that it calls for a
united approach
by the developer the council the schools
themselves
to address this very real issue
otherwise how can members support the
development of large number of owners
but there are no places for child school
children
in paragraph 117 on page 53 the lack of
school places is referred to
with an alternative being to employees a
grampian condition
which would prevent occupational
developments until the additional
primary school places are provided
i don't think that's a real option that
we would want to consider
chairman we can't ignore the misery
the real misery that would be caused to
families
is that had no school places in their
area
and we're not talking about one or two
children here
german we're talking about a large
number of children we we can't play past
the parcel and say who's responsible
we can't play past the parcel with
children's lives
thank you thank you councillor rigby
um i think we'll probably discuss in
more detail
council rugby's point but i'd just like
to let all the members
uh come in and and have their say um
councillor thomas like to comment
thank you chad similar to council
williams i'm
very much in favor of
this this scheme uh and again likewise
disappointed regarding social housing
aspect of the scheme um but
leaving that aside and some things have
been mentioned already
i'm i'm very very concerned that from
what i understand
the improvements of the flicks and road
junction will be
the introduction of either a filter lane
or
a double lane to ease for
a certain number of meters to ease the
um
the strain on the single lane that's
there at the moment i don't think that's
really going to have much impact on
easing the the situation as it is you
can very very frequently
coming either up flicks and road towards
partington or the other way
encounter long lines of traffic and
adding houses to this without
improvement so certainly the county and
relief road would be um
a very big part of that
transport for general manchester hasn't
been mentioned here the bus routes
from people i know that live in partisan
and speak to me about it
are not the best accepting
social isolation at the moment and the
rules of governing
uh public transport that they're not
they're not the best so
in line with education even if you're to
move them into trafford schools within
the flicks in the rimstone area
or likewise into sail
and ashton the the bus routes for
secondary school children to go into
there are
not reliable the best um
in the comments from residents the roads
and the access to and from
partington which is woefully inadequate
um
as we know um that's that seems the main
thrust of what the complaints are
there are issues regarding amenities in
parkington to
um cope with the actual demand as it
goes along certainly if it goes into the
600 thousands
of forecast with only a couple small
supermarkets and
very little else in partington oil you
know hasten to admit that the people in
parkington
uh utilize that exceptionally well and
the people i know
like their little recent education again
i mentioned that
um the accessibility of
schooling uh even within the borough
without the salford or
warrington which i've not heard about i
think it's
absolutely imperative that we
as a council and the agencies involved
in
the the main thrust of the development
and the periphery like the
transport uh education would be
proactive proactive over this not
reactive because if we're reactive
things are delayed through whatever
reasons
and that will have an impact on both the
new residents and the existing residents
in parkington
and the surrounding area is a wider
remit
certainly regarding the highways issues
but
at the end of the day much needed
housing on brownfield sites
are going in place and perhaps as
commented by
council williams the developers can
perhaps look again
at who and what type of housing
there they want to to drive forward
certainly in part of the development
thank you thank you councillor thomas
councillor stanley uh thank you chair
i'm also going to echo many of the
um many of the points made by members
previously broadly i'm in favor of this
it is much needed housing it's on a
brownfield contaminated site it's not in
the green belt
and it helps for the regeneration of
partington
i also am concerned with the the housing
mix
i personally load the expression
affordable housing because it does it's
not it's not what it says on the can
affordable housing i couldn't afford
most of the schemes which are
classed as affordable housing that's not
something we're going to solve in this
um
in this planning committee so outside of
our remit
also that the the traffic impact even
with the carrington relief road i think
will be uh quite substantial
but that's down to the lack of public
transport and again i think as
within this committee we're not going to
solve and as a council we don't have
efficient control to either be able to
put more bus routes in place or
my idea would be to build more
railways or or metro but again this is
outside the remit
of this committee and there's also an
issue around schools so
there are lots to fault with this um
well with this proposal
but i think overall i'll be voting in
favor of it gives much needed housing
it's really development to partington
and it's um it's on a broadcast site
so thank you chair thank you councillor
when stanley councillor morgan
thank you chair um again i'm going to
sound um like an echo
um here and very much follow on from
councillor thomas and councilwoman
stanley
um i am very much broadly in favor of
this and i think building on as um
fantastic to have as many houses were
able to approve on a brownfield site
and tonight is really really great but i
do think
again what i really reiterate what
council rugby said in terms of
the the services that are behind some of
these developments
whether it be the transport but
particularly the schools um
i mean i i honestly do think to be able
to have as an
answer in a report to be saying that
there's a short-term solution is schools
in salford and warrington
is is shocking really absolutely
shocking
um um i mean it is a good distance from
bartington to
to to warrington and i honestly do think
that
we really really i mean i'm sure most of
the members of this committee are school
governors
and the issues that we have across the
borough
in terms of our primary school provision
which should be one of the main issues
that we're thinking about
um the the future of our children are is
vital
and we really really do need to to to
emphasize this and to to to push this up
in terms of that we really do need to
um emphasize that the problems i mean
councillor rigby
in the six months he's been on this
committee um council of bunting has
raised this on two big developments that
we have
um had in front of us um that
we don't have enough school provision in
the local area and i i
think having been very admittedly a good
while ago since i went to primary school
that
we should be encouraging the idea that
primary school children should be able
to walk
to their local primary school um and to
be considering dear to mean like
significant distances via bus for
primary school
children i think is really really
shocking um
but i do want to kind of kind of
summarize what though i will be
supporting this tonight because i think
the idea of building on brownfields
tonight
is fantastic and um and i i
i would struggle to oppose this um on
giving the the
the the support that that has so i will
be supporting this
um tonight chair but i do want to put in
my comments again
the issue about school provision
particularly but generally on services i
think really does need to be emphasized
um when we're coming up with these big
big developments thank you thank you
councillor morgan
um councillor menace
i think it's me first i think it's i
think it's dan first yeah
yeah sorry about that councillor jerome
you go ahead thanks jeff
um i'm probably going to book the trend
a little bit here because
um it's not entirely um brown built land
and when you do cycle to the this site
through carrington moss
you can see what a kind of unique
ecology it is for trafford
um and in the report one of the adverse
impacts it does mention
and that it gives substantial weight to
it's a loss of existing woodland
trees hedges and the wildlife habitats
which these
support including the ground nesting
birds and i think one of the compelling
objections
has come from cheshire wildlife trust um
and what they say they point to
a trafford core strategy
and in that core strategy uh policy r2
requires developers to protect and
enhance the landscape character
biodiversity geo-diversity and
conservation
of its natural urban and countryside
assets
and it's up to the developer to
compensate or mitigate
um as the policy states um so
looking at the landscape and ecology
plan
for the site it does do a lot of good
things
um it looks to improve the the woodland
that will be kept and puts in a good
management plan which i support
but if you look at some of the soft
landscaping such as the hedgerows
um there is a plan to keep picking out
things such as docks
sizzles nettles ragwort and williherb
which are all
native plants to this country especially
ragwort which is a
a a really important pollinating uh
plant in this country
and supports many kind of insects and
but yet
one of the plans that in this landscape
and ecological management plan
is to use glycophage weed killer so
you can see that their plan is very
manicured and they're going to be using
a herbicide and that we
moved most a policy to phase out in
trafford
but this this developer would will be
using a glycophage weed killer
as part of their weed control not only
on the uh soft landscaping
but on the hard hardscape landscaping
too on the paths play areas etc
um so i don't think they do enough to
mitigate the loss that we'll be seeing
from the
um ecological benefits that already
existed on the site
which i think uh cheshire wildlife trust
go
go on to mention the skylarks lap wings
um
slow work the possible slow worms that
are on site the waterfalls
and i don't think enough is being done
to to mitigate that
um which which i think is quite poor
from chatha's perspective
because carrington moss is it is a
unique place
and if we are going to be building on it
we should really mitigate that loss
um that's very important to me um
and i would go on to echo the point
about schools that we heard from
uh councillor rigby who spoke so well on
that i would agree with that
and the lack of transport public
transport in place for partington
um i don't think that can support the
600 houses
and uh just to finish off another reason
why i won't be supporting this
is the via viability report um
the planning department in this report
say it hasn't
demonstrated to be robust and i think
the level of affordable housing is quite
a low percentage here
and if we are going to build on
carrington moss we should be we should
be looking for
you know that target nearer to 40 and we
should be having some social housing too
um but saying that there is a really
good mix of family homes on this site
which which i do like
and there is quite a good mix of family
homes in the affordable housing which is
also good
but overall i don't think this plan
does enough and one of the benefits that
we're told
um in favor of this uh application
is the relief road and i don't
believe the relief road will be
beneficial to this area
um i i think the plan for the relief low
relief road
is just going to bring hordes of traffic
off the m60
and then link it up to altringham in the
airport and that will bring with it
pollution
um congestion and
won't be beneficial to the area and i
wouldn't support
giving this this money to that scheme i
think another
they should look look at that again and
put in another scheme in place
so this is a really hard application for
me to support and
i think chair i'll probably be refusing
it
thank you thank you councillor jerome
councillor minis
uh thank you chair um i was trying to
look
trying to balance the um the idea of
obviously
i'm very much um wanting brownfield
development
um but i have um quite a list of
reservations
um so my issues um
come from uh how well thought out i
guess is probably the best uh summary of
it
and this has all been so whilst you see
on the face of it
a lovely application with lots of uh
green spaces in it etc
we see that actually it comes at a loss
of
um habitat for local wildlife that
already exists there
um we see that actually even for the
humans that are going to
reside there once the the habitat is
lost to the the animals that live there
already
um that we then have the the
the humans can't smell send their small
humans to school
uh locally uh we are wanting and i
believe that this is
this is definitely a thing to try and
encourage children to walk
to school and uh being a mother of
of of a small child which i think he
might have heard just then when he's
out just outside the room um you know
you can't they can't really they're not
realistically not going to walk much
much further than a mile to get to
school and so you need to have
schools nearby which that you're not
going to have here
so i don't really know uh what sorts
you've talked about family homes
families generally consist of
children as well and the children need
to go to school somewhere
and they and we don't really want people
having to drive
miles and miles get their children to
school so
whilst i l i love brownfield development
and i'm
very much for that i feel like the
the um it's almost then that they are
trying to have some
places for animals to to then live and
they're trying to have mitigation
there i i'm not i'm not 100
sure that it's enough and i think that
the school issue
is uh big enough for me to tip it
definitely into the
uh i don't think i can support it really
and
i i think if they if they'd thought
about schools and infrastructure and
and medical surgeries etc i think that
you know i could possibly
and a bit more was considered about um
you know not using uh what we're banning
as a weed killer
etc you know if they had actually
thought a bit further maybe i could get
pushed into that that end but i think
i'm going to um they're going to have to
vote again thank you thank you
councillor minis
um councillor hartley you wait to come
back
sorry chair thank you yeah i just wanted
to comment on on the application
as a whole um so i'm i'm i think i'm i'm
broadly supportive of the application
i i do think it is quite a quite a
challenging application
to to to look at and you know i'm
looking at it for the for the first time
really
i think um there's a lot to like about
about the application
uh which other other members of of have
made clear really delivers obviously
a substantial contribution to trafford's
housing shortage
developing uh you know a predominantly
brownfield
site you know which is which is
contaminated
um you know so those are the main
benefits there are there are things
about
i think the design is good i quite like
the design of the hoses particularly
the sort of phase two houses it's good
to see something a bit
a bit different um and you know i like i
like the
the rare green space has been
incorporated um i think that's good
there are features on it that i don't
like uh
disappointed in the affordable housing
uh and also the
the type of affordable housing that is
and and and i suppose disappointed
disappointed with the developers
attitude
to that which which i sort of got a
sense of by by reading about the
negotiations um
in the reports and you know i applied
off applaud officers for
for trying to you know up that
contribution to affordable housing
um the report just talked about cycle
ways
i couldn't really see that on the plans
there's lots of paths but no no
specific cycling infrastructure that i
could see
um and and i do think it is is
perhaps more finally balanced in my mind
than the
than the report uh suggests so that you
know the report does weigh up well the
the the benefits and the adverse impacts
i know that when the committee looked at
this on the previous occasion
you know some of the adverse impacts
they said were outside the control of
the developer
um i think i think that's less so now so
actually i think some of those
adverse impacts in my mind have a bit
more weight now because
um the developer could do something
about it they could make a contribution
um i take fully take on board the
officer's point that
it wouldn't it wouldn't seem right to do
that now but the fact is they
they could so those impacts are not
being mitigated when when they could
so i i do think those adverse impacts
which are um
this summarized then on page one one
five
page three three seven uh paragraph
three through seven of the report
i do think they carry um a bit more
weight actually than this
suggested um suggested in the in the
report
um and but but the benefit
the benefits which i think we have to
give substantial weight to the addition
to the housing need
uh on a on a brownfield site and and the
report does explain quite well i think
that
you know the the tilted balance test in
the mpp
f um does talk about
you know where the most important
policies are out of date and i think
that's the case here because the most
important policies are
i think uh rl uh l1 and l2 r2 and l3
which is about the housing need and i
think they are the most important
policies there out of day and
so i think you know i think the tilted
balance
probably probably means that i would
support this
uh the the last thing i would say chair
and i know a lot of this is not
with within this committee's uh in this
committee's powers really but i would
echo a lot of the
a lot of the other comments really that
um
you know what what's disappointing is
that this is um
building developments in in parsington
and keratin is a real challenge because
they're not sustainable locations
um and i sort of think approving
parcels of land and building a lot of
housing on them
it undoubtedly makes a big contribution
to her to uh housing needs and traffic
but
doing it in that way we're not building
sustainable communities
uh and i do feel quite strongly about
that so if we continue to
and this is more a plea really we
continue to build houses in that
location
without ensuring that there's investment
in in public transport which you know
which is woeful
to that area um and without ensuring
investment in primary school places
which are obviously needed
uh without investing in sports
facilities in that location it
it's not i don't i don't agree with the
report when it says well there's
you know there's there's the sports
facilities in sale and altering them you
know which
it shouldn't need a child to get on a
bus in parson and get to those locations
and i do agree you know it shouldn't the
families moving into this area shouldn't
need to get into the car and drive their
child to a primary school
um you know a good a good distance away
that that is not a sustainable community
uh and and i and and i i hope you know i
hope the carrington leaf
does come forward i do think that's
needed but i do think we really need to
look at
um you know the strategic investment in
this location because it because it just
won't work if we build
you know thousands of houses there
without building them as part of
sustainable
communities um so
with that sort of reservation and i
suppose you know that that
disappointment
i think on on for planning reasons
there's a lot to say in favor of the of
the application
so um i i will be voting for it um
but i would just you know really issue
that plea that we've we've got to
do this in a more sustainable way i
think thank you chair
thank you councillor hartley councillor
holden did you want to come in
i know you commented in the chat but
did you want to vocalize your comments
no thank you i think that my comment is
exactly what it was said i support the
concerns about the schools and medical
facilities
the sustainability wonderful word
something that plantington
won't have if we keep loading these
housing developments into it
without some sort of consideration
of spare school space or additional
school space
we don't even have enough in sale
and sale west now so to actually suggest
in the report
that you can bus children to schools
that don't have places for them
is mad but having said that
the development is
good in itself and i think we as a
council need to be working
on these capacity issues of our own bat
and not waiting for the developers to do
something
so i didn't want to vocalize about it
and i've just taken up about three or
four minutes
so i'm sorry about that it's fine
thank you council holder um councillor
williams wants to
speak but i think miss coley is just
going to give us some information miss
coley
yes thank you chairman i all i wanted to
say really is that
that this is this is almost what i call
a a legacy application
of the sill regulations um position we
found ourselves when the resolution came
forward
if the application had been submitted
was and was submitted now
or have been busy since september 2019 i
think our starting position would have
been a lot different
and the developers buy ability and uh
and
and land price would have needed to
reflect that um however
they found themselves in the position
they were in with the resolution
to grant in april 2019 in a position
where they where they simply couldn't
um uh provide us any contributions it
wouldn't have been lawful
um and to try and unpick that now 18
months on
was considered um complete completely
unreasonable
by by officers but in terms of the
comments about
um the future it is very much our view
that uh developments do need to be
contributing their
appropriate amounts to all all necessary
contributions um as we move forward and
i think we've seen that in the last few
committees where we've had major schemes
that come forward
more recently that we we have we have uh
managed to obtain
um a a far more um appropriate level of
contributions from those schemes thank
you chairman that's all i say
thank you miss coley councillor williams
thanks for your patience you want to
come in
thank you chad um i'll try not to drag
out proceedings much longer and i'll try
also not to engage in repetition i just
wanted to reflect on some of
the remarks that other members have said
um
i agree with what counselor hartley had
to stay around the the attitude that
we've seen from the developer
in terms of viability uh and their
contributions and i think the council of
jerome also
touched on that i i agree with
everything that they have to say that
now in terms of
um councillor jerome's remarks about um
the site itself i
i respect what he has to say about the
ecological impact but i suppose i
disagree with this characterization that
this is the development of
carrington moss this site to be clear
is in partington and to be further clear
and
as a booklet saint martin's world
council i've had the privilege of
touring the entirety of the
tacoma site of going around um all of
carrington moss of carrington and of
bartington you know the majority of this
site and this development
lies in what i would call brownfield
land proper
contaminated land it is not the
greenbelt and in my opinion
every property that we refuse for
development in a style like this
and let's be clear carrington mosque
proper is up for development
if released through um the gmsf
every site that we review every unit
that we refuse to deliver on a site like
this
is just going to be added on to
greenbeltland released through the gmsf
so that's why i'm enthusiastic about
developing
here now i respect what counselor rigby
had to say
around um educational placements and you
know councillor morgan referred to the
fact that councilman rigby
has um testified to the question of
educational placements on a number of
different applications now
but to my mind uh planning is always
about balance it's always a negotiation
that's what i i've experienced and
determining applications on this
committee previously and we have to
reflect on the fact
that this this application contains with
a significant contribution
toward improving highways measures
across um my ward and i see time and
time again
what amounts to in effect idling traffic
because we have such extensive
congestion along the one road in and out
of partington
that what happens is cars are just sat
there
on the road in rush hour to uh in peak
traffic
uh periods with their engines running
pumping out fumes and not moving at all
so we have to reflect on the fact that
the developer that this developer is
prepared
to make a sizeable financial
contribution toward improving that
situation
and making traffic flow better um i
i agree with members who have expressed
reservations about
some aspects of this development i
understand that but we have to weigh
this up
in balance and i think on balance and
there is more to gain from approving
this
application than from refusing it so
with that i i don't think it's been
proposed that we we vote in favor of
this application so i will move
that um we accept officer recommendation
and approve this application this
evening thank you jeff
thank you councillor williams and i was
going to comment myself but
truthfully council would have said
everything that wanted to say well
we all agree with everything that
everybody has said
concerns about transport and schools and
effects on the countryside but it is a
balance and
and the benefits just about for me um
tip the balance in favor of the
application and i may say 18 months ago
we
we were so excited about this
application and it doesn't seem fair to
me
to be to be to be coming up with a
different different story again
18 months later we were very
enthusiastic
um i've not got cancer uh thomas's
second did the application so
i was going to second it but counselor
thomas has gotten the first comment i
don't want to bring any more speakers
into it i really do think we've
we've debated this at length i know the
members what what it's a comment but um
uh i i really do think we need to we
need to move on so we'll go to
it's been moved and seconded moved by
council williams secretary by council
somerset we grant this application
and i'll go to the vote um councillor
morgan how would you like to vote
i approve in line with officer
recommendations jeff thank you
um council holden how would you like to
vote prove in line with officer
recommendations thank you councillor
minis how would you like to vote
um i'll be voting against officer
recommendation thank you thank you very
much
councillor thomas how would you like to
vote i'll approve
officer recommendations chair thank you
councillor jerome how would you like to
vote
against the recommendation thank you
councillor jerome councillor rigby how
would you like to vote
thank you very much council stenit how
would you like to vote
for the recommendation by the offices
thank you councillor williams how would
you like to vote
to approve in line with office of
recommendation thank you
thank you councillor hartley how would
you like to vote
thank you chair in favor of the officer
recommendation thank you thank you
council accordingly how would you like
to vote uh in line with officers
recommendation to approve
thank you councillor dr barclay
unfortunately he's able to take part
i'll be voting in favor of the officer's
recommendation councillor win stanley
how would you like to vote
in favor of officer's recommendation uh
to approve
thank you chair thank you councillor
stanley so that's 11
um 11 people in favor of the office
recommendation two people against
that application is approved the
application has been granted 10
10 2 and in favor against oh sorry
rather counter dr barry couldn't vote
that's right 10
10 in favor two against that's right 12
in total thank you
um i don't have any other
items on the agenda that concludes the
meeting
to